Google Voice allows you to have different voicemail greetings based on who is calling.
This is useful for example, if you want one message for work.
You've reached the cell phone of Jason Toss.
Please leave a message.
And another message for friends.
Hey, sorry I missed you.
Leave a message.
To set up a personalized greeting for someone,...
...go to that contact and select "Edit Google Voice Settings."
Choose a greeting you've already recorded or select "Record New Greeting"...
...and Google Voice will call your cell phone so you can record the greeting.
Start recording your greeting after the tone.
When you are finished, press #.
If you wanna set up a personalized greeting for a group,...
...just go to "Settings," "Groups," and click "Edit."
Then choose your greeting.